I'm speaking to you today as a
representative of
Monarch Monarch is a global
collaboration of governmental and
scientific agencies dedicated to the
study of massive unidentified
terrestrial organisms or MOS including
the creature we know as Godzilla now our
mission is to protect you the citizens
around the world we bring the best minds
and the most cuttingedge technology to
to this purpose including the early
warning system that was triggered in
Seattle yesterday unfortunately this
time it was just a false alarm and we
regret any distress this may have caused
but I take great comfort in knowing
robust systems are in place to give us
ample warning in a real
emergency
listen I know that the events of gday
they Rock the world a world where
everything that we love everything that
we hold dear it just could be gone in an
instant and let me tell you as a mother
I share your
fear but this is now the world we live
in monsters are an inescapable
reality a constant
threat that we must learn to
survive and I believe we
can together I believe we will
that is my commitment to
you